for the big day there is meticulous
planning
but right now for weddings it seems
there's no plan up ahead
at the colossal peckforton castle the
uncertainty is felt everywhere they just
don't know if and when weddings will
have to stop
stress is the
perfect word for it it's bringing back
nightmares of
earlier in the year and last year of
what we went through as a business
not only does chris run three busy
venues he also chairs the uk's wedding
task force but even having a direct link
to government the picture is no clearer
it makes me angry it really does this
time round i think anger is probably the
best way to describe it i think
it previously
i was i was happy to look and and go
with what the government was saying but
i think everything that's come out in
the last few weeks and the fact that
we're going back again to potentially to
a so-called step two is a huge backwards
step
new year's eve is supposed to be
hannah's happiest day but with the
current coveted condition she's staying
home not taking any risks and it's a
situation out of her hands it's horrible
i mean you know
when you're planning your wedding
everything is kind of um
stressful enough
and
i think as much as i'm i was really
looking forward to the day you know part
of you is kind of looking forward to
having that stress of the planning of
the wedding out of the way and the
thought of having to postpone it um
reschedule anything like that is just
like
oh oh yeah um yeah really stressful
it isn't just wedding venues and those
who are getting married here that are
now in the dark there is a huge knock-on
effect to this massive industry caterers
florists and photographers
all now uncertain
about the weeks ahead
i represent a demoralized decimated
exhausted sector
we were the first to close the last to
open
and here we face uncertainty yet again
we're of course aware of all the rumors
a circuit breaker
but
weddings are incredibly complex you
don't just start them and end them
with a few hours notice we need to know
what's the plan
the magic of weddings has been
overshadowed by endless uncertainty
the fairy tale many hoped for has been
suppressed
that will continue without a vow of some
clarity intimate rasheed sky news
cheshire